so today I want to talk to you about a
molecule which when it was first
isolated was called very fast death
factor now this molecule is a really
potent toxin and it's found in the pond
scum the green sort of gloopy algae
stuff that you find sometimes on
freshwater ponds and it's actually not
algae that makes this it's called
cyanobacteria and that green it turns
out is kind of really important for this
molecule as it turns out the molecule
itself is unstable to light so nature's
clever it didn't really it wants a toxic
molecule for some reason in that
cyanobacteria in that algal bloom but it
didn't want it to spread too much so as
soon as you take the molecule out of
that it becomes destroyed by light but
nonetheless don't let this fool you this
is a very very dangerous molecule so
I've got nearly 5 grams in this this
round bottom flask here that would be
enough to kill around 350 people this is
a seriously toxic molecule now luckily
for everyone involved this is actually
in a protected form this molecule you
see here in this flask this compound so
it's got a safety catch on it it's got
something called a protecting group and
it completely kills the reactivity of
one atom in this molecule the nitrogen
atom and that atom is key to the the
biological response that it will provoke
so if we quickly put that one down here
is a molecular model of Anna toxin a
which is the very fast death factor it
was renamed because that was thought not
to be particularly scientific well I
quite like very fast death that's it it
does what it says on the tin essentially
so here is here is that key nitrogen so
it turns out it's the nitrogen in this
oxygen over here and that distance which
is the key to its biological activity it
fits a certain receptor that one of your
neuro
natural neurotoxins triggers so this
molecule like si is it's a top
sin and what it does and why it's called
very fast death factor is that it
paralyzes somebody who ingests it be
that an animal a cow a rabbit bird or
whatever that's drinking from the pond
or somebody who drinks or swims in the
pond and it works really quickly thus
the name very fast death fat so it turns
out that a lot of potent toxins actually
work very slowly is there's an agonizing
death this works very very quickly a
matter of minutes rather than hours or
days what this does is it it stops your
brain communicating with your muscles so
nerves have two functions really one
they tell muscles and your body to move
be that breathe which is part you know
you're on autopilot you don't think
about breathing but every few seconds
your brain saying breathe in breathe out
breathe in breathe out it does it
automatically or all moving muscles so
if you stop any of those signals then
obviously your muscles stop and if you
stop breathing
you're gonna die pretty quick obviously
this compound is a very dangerous
compound so why earth would be we'd be
interested in making this an analogs of
this compound well it turns out that it
could be a good treatment for
Alzheimer's disease now if you imagine a
nervous system is a long piece of
electrical wire and every now and again
along that wire you'll get just like you
do at home a plug in a socket where two
bits of wire join now in electricity the
plug in the socket are made of metal and
the electrons can hop from one to the
other and there's no problem in nervous
transmission there's a little gap in
between the plug in the socket and those
little molecules called
neurotransmitters which come out of one
end they swim across the gap and they
trigger the response in the other end of
the synapse as it's called and then the
electrical signal goes on again now
obviously you don't want those
electrical signals to be on all the time
so the little molecule comes back out
and there's a pac-man trap molecule
which comes and munches those up to make
sure that you know the response is gone
we now need to get rid of those and
wait for the next signal now in certain
conditions like Alzheimer's disease your
normal neurological condition degrades
some what they're called
neurodegenerative diseases but nerves in
your brain don't work properly and the
problem is that you get too many of
these pac-man molecules taking up too
many of those transmitters and so yeah
your nervous system your brain isn't
working properly now it could be that
molecules like this which are able to
disable these pac-man molecules could be
very useful leads to treatment of
Alzheimer's disease and other
neurodegenerative diseases so that's why
as chemists we're interested in these
things we're not interested obviously in
killing 350 people